hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast then ah
ass checking in on you
just checking in to see how your week's
going
um
I've been watching a lot of sports hey
by the way by the [__] way if you
listen to my last podcast
kind of everything that I said was going
to happen both in the basketball
finals and the Stanley Cup Final kind of
happened
you know and I didn't see one [__]
person
one tweet one twiddle one [__]
Instagram nothing going like hey man
that was a good call
you know
well I will reiterate what did I say
after game one
when the [__] uh nuggets semi blew
out the Miami Heat
even though they cut it down to nine
I said with the [__] end of the game
Jimmy Butler was already
strategizing whatever the [__] word
is that would have made me nervous I
said something like that no I didn't say
I guess I didn't say they're definitely
going to win game two
but I don't know all right you got me on
that one all right but the [__] the
hockey one
you know what I was talking about I was
waiting for that [__] call since 2018
I told you the Florida Panthers are a
six with a bunch of makeup on and
everybody thinks they're a [__] 10
they don't have a Norris Trophy winner
they don't have a [__] Ovechkin
all right they're playing whistle to
whistle and then when shit's not going
their way they try to start some [__]
and they punch a goal scorer in the head
three times when he retaliates the
[__] refs call matching roughing
miners
right but what happened
what the [__] happened the referees got
it right in game one
they called they gave they gave the
Panthers a four minute [__] power
play and they gave Chuck a [__] gay
misconduct
and I said right there they cracked the
[__] code all they gotta do Play
Whistle the whistle and when they try
that rough [__] that [__] punk ass
[__] because there's no [__] Probert
to come over and beat the [__] out of
them
right because they got rid of guys like
that in the league
all they got to do is just put the
helmet down take the punches to the head
and and then that's going to be it
they're going to look like a [__]
eighth seed and what happened game two
the [__] Vegas Knights went out there
and and mopped the floor with them seven
to two
shout out to kachakto with that a
beautiful
legal shoulder to shoulder
open Ice hint
um
all of a sudden their goalie's looking
regular right all of a sudden they're
getting [__] traffic in front of them
not saying this series is over but
um
I don't know I was so [__] frustrated
watching you know my team not Play
Whistle to whistle and then whatever the
[__] Maple Leafs were doing against
them
I mean for the first the I have said
this it's the only time they've escorted
them into their own [__] Zone
look like a five on three at even
strength
for the first three games and they're
like oh wait a minute maybe maybe we
should you know
[__] hit somebody
they win game four and that was it was
too late it was too late it was [__]
it's [__] irritate me
it's irritate me the way like when I
watch the St Louis Blues when the
[__] cup and and the guys were going
like you know this guy this kid net I
tell you this is reminding me of Patrick
Wa it's reminding you of Patrick War
Patrick war never got pulled out of a
game in the [__] finals what the f
what the [__] are you talking about why
do I give a [__]
why do I give a [__] to this level huh
you know why because it's all I got
that in a [__] cup of coffee every
once in a while
oh [__] Billy dries a bone
you know I think what I'm gonna do every
month is just I'm just [__] everything
except coffee
that's what I'm gonna do and I'm just
gonna sit there like the goddamn [__]
bald curmudgeon Ginger that I am and I'm
just gonna sit around drinking coffee
talking about the way things used to be
[Music]
oh my God I got shut down so bad by this
[__] old dude
oh my God I was at this coffee shop and
I was killing it with the small talk I
was in a great [__] mood you know
hanging out with my beautiful wife you
know just having a great time
and uh
I don't know I don't know what the [__]
I was talking about and it was just it
was this [__] guy in the corner he's
playing that game here you throw the
dice and then you move the checkers up
and down as they're black and white like
I don't know what's I don't know what
the part cheesy I don't know what the
[__] it's called and he looked really
angry
and he looked like he wanted to be alone
right
so my wife you know she comes over and I
go look at that [__] guy over there
Jesus Christ
the guy's got some goddamn issues
um steering clear of him and she goes
you know he would probably like nothing
better than if he went over and said
hello to him
and I was like really I don't think so
but I am kind of fascinated with that
game right
and I didn't think anything of it and I
I had my little [__] uh mini
cappuccino
and you know me I got nothing else I got
nothing else to give me a [__] buzz
in life so I say [__] it I'm getting
another one so I go in there I make some
small talk with this [__] lady
you know for the Pacific Palisades we
headed off we're laughing we're joking
around
and I come walking I'm like you know
[__] it I'm gonna walk up to that angry
guy who's clearly saying don't [__]
walk up to me because my wife's going
like you know what he'd probably enjoy
it and I'm in a good mood and all of a
sudden I think I'm Billy fresh face
gonna turn somebody's life around and I
walked up I go hey man what is that how
do you how do you play that game game of
ice you know by yourself alone or
whatever I don't even if I got it out
and the guy just without even looking up
just put his hand up he goes sir please
I'm enjoying my alone time
so I [__] you know I just turn around
and I'm [__] laughing right and I see
the blonde lady who I was [__]
shooting the [__] with and she looked at
me smiled and I winked like you know
whatever you know [__] guys
this guy's angry I went I [__] sat
down
and Nia was going like oh [__] he
[__]
he [__] shut you down I'm like that
is the second [__] time you've done
to that to me this year
you told me to go up to Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar I knew he didn't want
anybody coming up to him but you wanted
a picture so [__] bad and I went up
to him and he was he just
oh God
I can finally think about that without
cringing that [__] conversation
um
that's the second time and you know what
they say bad things come in threes right
people bad things coming through which
makes no sense bad things don't come in
threes bad things happen
good things happen you know you just you
just count up to three and then go back
to zero again
that's what's happening
all right you could say bad things
happen in 17s
if he just kept going
and 17 is not even divisible by three is
it I don't think it is
then again I went to public school and
and a lot of people's math doesn't make
sense to me like you know what [__]
drives me up the wall
oh I'm on one right now I'm [__] on
one I you [__] annoys the [__] out of
me every goddamn [__] stupid playoff
series
all right the favorite gets the first
two games at home
right and if the other team wins one
game they go they now have home court
advantage how the [__] do they have home
court advantage
how the [__] does that like somebody
please explain that to me
you're still gonna play four games
in my building
what because you won one of them somehow
I don't have four games
what like what is the I could win the is
it because after that the the the the
underdog has three home games
and the other person only has two
well that's gonna happen even if I win
the first two games
after two if you don't start counting
them if you [__] go back to zero
there's five games left three of them
are in your [__] building what are we
doing here is it because you want it in
my game in in my Arena
right
and now I got three away games in your
Arena now you're suggesting that the
home team automatically [__] wins
which obviously they don't because you
split it home
the [__] are you talking I I just feel
like that is just some invented
you know ESPN just trying to add drama
they they didn't take away him home
court game seven is still in your
[__] building
so is game five
the [__] are we doing here
sorry
well they took away home home court
advantage is that what they did
is that what just happened there
who gives a [__]
who gives it well I gotta go I go to
your [__] building and let me guess
did they hand out plastic sticks for
them to slam together underneath the
[__] hoop like every other goddamn
Arena they go to do you realize how not
distracting that is to an NBA player I
actually think an NBA player is so
[__] used to people doing all of that
[__] what it actually would freak them
out if you just sat there like gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen you were quiet
you're like shh like he was lining up a
putt then I think it would be weird to
him I feel the same way about icing a
field goal kicker it's it's it's like
part of kicking a field goal it's like
all right I'm gonna [__] you know
warm up here and he's gonna call it
there it is he called the time out I've
got a little little [__] stretch here
okay here we go all right here we go
this one's for all the [__] at Hooters
right you [__] line it up you kick it
right down the middle he's got [__]
ice water in his mind he doesn't
he doesn't have ice water in his fans he
should that's just part of it
oh
Bill what are you really upset about oh
I don't know
[__] zillion things a zillion [__]
things
it's so weird because I just you
wouldn't know it I just took a little
mini two-day
you know
vacation with my lovely wife it's in
between our birthdays
we went away we had a great [__] time
went away in my truck we stayed in a
little [__] Airstream
it was just away from everybody and we
had a [__] great time and then the
second I [__] get back to
civilization
hit this [__] traffic hit this
[__] traffic out here
foreign
10 30 in the morning bumper to bumper
traffic it's like none of you are going
to work unless you're driving a truck
if you're driving an 18-wheeler you're
at work the rest of you wear the [__]
how are you not late
does everybody sort of work remotely now
is that what the [__] it is or is that
just like a whole bunch of Uber drivers
um
I don't know so I sit in this [__]
traffic
oh a [__] hour of traffic
at 10 30 in the morning
and uh
hit a little breakfast spot get some
coffee with my wife and then I had to go
my little egg beater helicopter every
hundred hours they got to do you know
change the oil check all the liquids
whatever all the fluids are whatever the
[__] I'm not a mechanic
they make sure everything's what it's
supposed to be right
so I gotta fly this [__] thing
right over the goddamn Highway where I
just sat in the traffic
set the [__] dick down I get an Uber
I'm coming back and the exact same spot
I got in traffic I sat in it again
same amount of traffic it doesn't matter
what time it just doesn't matter I saw
an article where they were saying that
they were going to start maybe charging
people to use the [__] highways
to try and lessen traffic it's like okay
wait a minute our tax dollars built
those [__] things
and now you're going to make us pay for
them again you're going to do that to
hard-working people man I'm a comedian I
don't [__] work hard
I don't mind
paying a little extra
you know
I guess that's not how it works though
right
I like when they ask rich people to
[__] pay a little extra and they get
upset
you know
that's [__] socialism oh [__] you you
[__]
you broke a union and you moved your
widget Factory to a [__] someplace
where they have no rights and now
they're selling your [__] together for a
dollar a month why don't you throw some
money in the [__] till
all right you [__] pleaded slack
swearing son of a [__]
um God I was so [__] rested
I don't know what happened
I don't know what happened my daughter
was hilarious tonight
she goes dad can I have a snack
I go will you not eating anything bad
you gotta have something healthy
all right
she goes all right what are my options
[Music]
that's the hardest part
about being a parent is your kids are
[__] hilarious and I I I'm the worst
I laugh every time and then they laugh
and then they get what they want
I forget what I was watching tonight I
was watching something I went ah Jesus
Christ and my daughter goes Jesus Christ
and I go don't say that
she goes why guy you know it's a bad
word I almost said it's taking the
lord's name in vain but I don't believe
in that [__] so I'm just like hey you
know
it annoys people and she goes well then
why do you say it
and I was like ah because my dad said it
he said all the words he said him all
the time and he set him in front of us
and
even though I knew they were bad and the
fact that he was saying them
didn't make it me you know to make it
seem that bad
she was just like well then why
she didn't have to say I'm like yeah now
I'm doing it again
yeah my son said God damn it the other
day
he goes God damn it
we were like what and he goes he goes he
goes God damn garbage truck
ah it's the worst anyone's funny is when
that [__] happens everybody just turns
and looks at me like they never say God
damn it you know look if they say [__]
okay that is me
uh
I gotta get that under control
I just said you know what
I said it like [__] three times I'm
saying it now I said it like three times
tonight right
I just I
I mean what what other word is there
when you're upset
ah gee whiz
maybe that's what I'll do I'll just mock
being angry then I can just find the
silliness in it
uh
Randy vataha I'm trying to think of old
football players names
uh for the love of Harry Carson
that's not that's it that's just nothing
now Will Chamberlain
it's gonna be somebody more oh Eddie
deason
uh you got to be Lou granting me I it
just doesn't work
is there anything better than oh what
the [__]
of course it didn't because the [__]
thing [__] [__] [__]
is anybody like there's no way anybody
who listens to this podcast doesn't
curse on a regular basis or swear as we
used to say
um
does anybody out there
you know swear like a sailor like I do
and and you had kids and you were you
successfully
were able to stop
you know
I've really been trying to not do that
I was in the middle of [__] nowhere
and then I couldn't remember I just
still swearing I was in the middle of
nowhere
driving back
you know and I really connected with my
wife and we really just
talked about how much we loved each
other and everything
and you know I told her I was going to
work on my temper
but I said you know you remember the
last time we really had a knock down
drag it out we couldn't even remember it
like we're getting along so great but
like just my day-to-day [__]
so right after I said that right
we're in the middle of nowhere in the
[__] mountains and you know my GPS
isn't working too good so I had to kind
of stop at a stop sign I had not seen a
car in a [__] hour
it's how far away we were right and uh
I get to the stop sign I'm trying to
figure out if I go left or if I go right
so I'm looking at the GPS and of course
some [__] [__]
drives up right behind me
and I was like what you got to be funny
there's always somebody [__] coming
out look and I just immediately shut it
down
pulled over the side of the road let the
guy go by he gave me the wave which is
very rare out here in California they do
not do the wave if you wave at them they
look at you like what the [__] evidently
that's an East Coast thing
you know
and um
I don't know whatever what am I going to
become a [__] perfect person
I'm laying off the booze oh [__] you
know what the other night I went down to
The Comedy Store I went down on the
wrong night
got a little confused with the booker
right
so I go down Sunday night and I come
walking in and she just assumes she goes
she just goes like Oh my
she's like what are you doing here
I go you told me to come down tonight
she's like no that was tomorrow I go I
can't go down tomorrow
doing a little two-day thing with my
wife
and she was like oh okay
um I go just throw me on at the end of
this show I'll mop up in the end
and she was just like yes hey
it's a benefit for battered women and I
was just like
I think they I don't
I was like all right
okay I can handle that and then she left
and I somebody else said it she goes
yeah and go and I think they're gay too
and I was like all right
you know what the [__] right so
I go out there
and I keep teasing him about
but getting slapped around getting shook
and all of that type of stuff and I was
about 10 minutes into my set
and they s and somebody yelled out they
go we're not battered women
we're alcoholics
I heard I thought they told she'd said
alcoholics but for some reason I heard
battered women I don't know why
so they go we're not battered women
we're alcoholics
and I was like oh
you guys are a bunch of drunks ah you're
my people
and they had the best sense of humor
about being booze bags
and I was joking around with them going
like you know I'm like you I'm not all
the way like you guys
like you know when I was growing up they
said you know addiction
you know either were or you weren't and
I don't think it's like that I go it's
like a spectrum
it's like I stopped drinking and you
know
I I basically you know wherever my
addiction is is I can't have alcohol in
the house
and they laughed and I go the same way I
can't have cookies in the house I'm
gonna [__] consume it
but like
I go but once you get the alcohol out of
the house I'm fine I go I'm not like you
people well you know I start walking
down the street like a zombie [__]
blowing people
you know to get a [__] bottle of wine
or whatever and they were [__] laugh
they were so cool
um
I tried some new [__] this [__] idea
I have
that is just I just can't seem to I said
it right the first night and I I never
record myself because I never listen to
it
it was stupid and then I would have all
these [__] recordings and then I
would look at the and just be like uh
beat myself up for not looking at them
and I just find he's like well you're
not you don't listen to recordings why
don't you stop [__] recording
yourself
which has worked great for me but then
like except when I'm having a problem
with something so I just gotta
whatever I got a bunch of Road dates
coming up and then I got a uh I gotta
run a date so I don't know if they
announced them yet but I got I'm gonna
do some warm-up shows here
in LA to make sure I'm up to speed and
I'm very excited about that
and um
yeah
I'm excited to get back out on the road
and uh God knows I got like three weeks
three weekends in a row coming up not
bad for a [__] old man huh
I wonder if I stopped doing stand-up
if I was if I would curse less I just
don't think that that would happen
because I grew up hearing it
and then I got in I you know I've worked
in sales I worked in warehousing
briefly was in construction I mean those
people are like it's
it transcends swearing it's like poetry
I remember there was this guy
I never really heard anybody
to say this before
he yelled at this guy on the site he
goes
he goes hey [__] [__]
dude we all fell on the [__] ground
laughing he gave the guy a first and
last a [__] [__]
so that was one of my
[Music]
that was my favorite other than that I
feel like with like
like cursing for me
uh
for me it's it's all about like I think
the best
at it is is England Ireland and Scotland
they're the funniest
just the way that they the the stuff
that they say
and how the the word conscious flies
around it's just I don't know maybe
because I'm a [__] tourist here and
it's just the funniest [__]
uh
you silly [__]
I remember the first time I heard that I
was watching Led Zeppelin The Song
Remains the Same and somebody at Madison
Square Garden was selling bootleg
Zeppelin [__] so Peter Grant arguably
the greatest [__] manager of all time
is taking the head of security to task
over it and the guy actually has the
audacity to be like well I mean I you
know how am I supposed to know
what's going on in every corner of this
place and he goes well you're in charge
of security you silly [__]
like what do you say to that
it's just so [__] perfect well yeah I
mean it's just a
it just so there's nothing better than
when somebody has somebody dead to
rights and they just hit you with that
level of just [__]
just matter of fact it wasn't even
hostile
he just stated the fact
what am I supposed to yeah you are
supposed to know this your head of
security
then he adds you silly [__]
it's one of my favorite [__]
I don't know just watching somebody you
didn't even have to curse him out
that was the end of it and the guy had
like nothing to say I mean also you know
Peter Grant was a big [__] dude all
right I got some live dates here
um oh some live read dates and live
reads all right pre-sale for All Dates
ends Thursday at midnight code Burr
b-u-r-r For What on sale Friday 10 a.m
local time
for these shows uh on Tuesday
October 3rd Syracuse New York
at the on-center War Memorial Arena
Saturday October 7th Canton Ohio
the [__] out of here
at the Tom Benson Hall of Fame Stadium
what
must be like a [__]
offshoot to the Sunday October 8th I'm
in Milwaukee Wisconsin my favorite
[__] City
uh the Pfizer Forum well it's a Pfizer
Forum
f-i-s-e-r-v
f-i-s-e-r-v Forum Sunday November 5th
I'm at Foxwood Connecticut at the
Foxwood Resort Casino for two shows 5
P.M
getting the blue-haired crowd there and
8 P.M Tuesday November 7th I'm in
Norfolk Virginia at the Norfolk scoop
Arena Wednesday November 8th I'm in
Atlanta Georgia at the State Farm Arena
Thursday November 9th
uh Hollywood Florida at the Hard Rock
Hotel
and Friday November 17th I'm at the Las
Vegas Nevada I'm in Las Vegas Nevada at
the Dolby live and I'm also there for
that F1 race which is going to be sick
right down the [__] strip
um
you know it's crazy November 9th when
I'm in Hollywood Florida I might be
right up the street from the NBA in
Stanley Cup [__] champs as much as I
was making fun of the [__] Florida
Panthers
you know they still could do it I'm not
counting them out but I think I think
those Vegas Knights got them figured out
because that guy that could chuck lit up
came back
and they asked about sorry yawning here
they asked them at the end of the uh the
end of the game
about the hit he was just like I know
hockey's a rough sport I'm still sick
all right that dude's a [__] man
he's shaking it off
um I will say though I love kachuk I
love his [__] game I mean the guy
literally
got matching penalties with the [__]
goaltender I mean
that's that's pretty goddamn impressive
got a goaltender out of the [__] out
of his game all right we got some reads
here indochino you know looking shap all
wedding season long shouldn't be
expensive
exactly it shouldn't be it's one [__]
night
the [__] are you gonna do with that suit
just go to indochino
with the custom fitted suit from
indochino you'll create Priceless
Memories without costing a fortune and
let me tell you something nobody [__]
notices
whether it's an indochino suit or if
it's from [__] Tom Ford you know who
knows the difference the people the
salesman at Tom Ford
everybody else is like wow I like that I
like that suit and you're like yeah
175 bucks
um I don't think it's that cheap
whatever customize every detail on your
suit shirt dinner jacket and more you
know what's great about a cheap suit too
you can get to a fight wearing it you
don't give a [__]
you know you're drinking your [__]
day can spill a drink on it you don't
give a [__]
you look good
you [__] get another one
it's indochino
uh customize every detail on your suit
shirt dinner jacket or more in a range
of colors who has a [__] dinner
jacket
would you just come back from a fox hunt
uh from a traditional black or gray to
burgundy or Olive
nice colors to a classic Hemsworth Navy
every suit is made to your exact
measurements hey I wonder if that
red-headed kid who left the royal family
is now wearing [__] indochino
[Music]
every suit is made to your exact
measurements and you can customize every
detail create a suit that fits you and
your style perfectly with options for
Fabrics lapel shape custom Monograms I
like custom Monograms that's some old
school man [__] you put your [__] uh
I someone said address you put your
initials on the on the Cuffs you get
some cuff links
you get yourself a big ass American car
right
and you tell these [__] what time it
is I'm sorry uh create a suit that fits
you uh and your style perfectly with
options for fabric lapel shapes custom
Monograms statement Linings and more
they also have tuxedos starting at
579. why rent when you could buy a
custom tux you can re-wear for years to
come exactly uh they're always adding
New pieces options so you can stay on
Trend and in style RSVP knowing you got
the perfect look all wedding season long
from indochino go to indochino.com and
use the code Burr to get 10 off any
purchases a 3.99 or more that's
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code Burr
all right who do we got oh lastly but
not leastly it's simply safe everybody
um
if you've listened to this show before
you've probably heard me talk about
SimpliSafe you know they were named the
best home Securities of 2023 by US News
and World Report so they're probably
resting on their lures right
no definitely not they're not they're
always innovating
uh always working on the next thing to
help keep you and your loved ones safe
24 7 like their new two-in-one smoke and
CO detector
what the [__] is co
carbon monoxide would be cm
[Music]
all right oh God I sucked in chemistry
class
chemistry I didn't even get to it I
didn't even get to it
I didn't even I never even took a
chemistry class they were just like the
same for you buddy the same for you
you're gonna take a class called project
physics
um anyway it's next Generation Hazard
detection that
distinguishes between fire and cooking
smoke
so your home is protected and you get
fewer false alarms well that's cool
uh their new smoke and CO detector
senses a sensor joined simply saves
comprehensive Suite of advanced security
cameras sensors and Hazard detectors for
seamless whole home monitoring with
simply saved 24 7 Professional
monitoring Services trained agents stand
ready to respond to an emergency
dispassion dispatching police
firefighters or EMTs to your door even
if you're away or can't be reached
monitoring Services costs under a dollar
a day Simply Safe is easy to set up
yourself or have a certified technician
install it for you and there's no reason
to wait within with financing through a
firm you can secure your home today and
pay overtime and installments in an in
installments that fit your budget right
now get 20 off your new system when you
sign up for interactive monitoring visit
simplysafe.com that's simplysafe.com
there's no safe
like SimpliSafe
all right that's it
um
as much as I was breaking the Florida
Panthers [__] balls uh I'm hoping
they win game three because I wanna I
want seven games
uh NHL and I want seven games NBA and
you know what I saw the NBA's
um
commissioner silver whatever his name is
talking about what a great year it was
in the NBA and how many teams were
involved in uh and could have made the
playoffs or whatever so there goes a lot
of my theories
about the NBA
um
so I hope he's right I hope it is going
to be like this because I love that it's
Denver in Miami
it's a nice different final right finals
Stanley Cup Final
um
we shall see
we shall see what happened
um but I like all the cheesy Miami Heat
fans
coming down there dressed in white
you know
like that's the style I noticed a couple
of the the sports broadcaster guys
were wearing their [__]
white jackets which is funny because
they're both old as [__] you know
like where you going
we all know you're going to bed after
the [__] game you got to look up the
stats you got to know what you're
talking about uh all right that's it go
[__] yourselves have a great weekend you
[__] and I will uh I'll talk to you on
Monday
oh by the way enjoy the music here that
end with them was picked out and uh then
we have a bonus episode of the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
over there
June 8th
2015. what's going on
I can't [__] say it anymore man I'm
ready to come home
I've had a great time over here uh
and uh you know but no matter how much
of a good time you have and at some
point you miss your stuff you want to go
home and see your dog
you know
you'd just like to [__] speak your
own Lang I'm so [__] sick of trying
to speak this [__] over here I'm having
a great time my French is better than
it's ever been
uh but I am [__] you know
the mem shows people play that means
more the same if you're ever in a bar
and you finally get your [__] out
whatever you wanted
you know what I mean
you know juvedere my [__] Jack
Daniels
on ice or whatever once you get that
[__] out they know what the [__] you're
saying when they come back you know and
they're like you know we miss you you
just point your glass you go the mem
should play
and they go are we and they walk away
and they come back and magically they
give you another [__] uh
I don't have a glass or whatever the
[__] you just ordered and um I also
found out over here that I like green
beans
I always thought green beans it's like
ah whatever you know
I forget what they call them over here
Arrow got I can't even remember I
[__] look at it and I can read it and
I know how to say it you know
uh you know Java Dre uh salad
vet whatever the [__] you say right and
all it is is green beans is a little bit
of [__] this mustard dressing they
put on them
and I gotta tell you it's out of this
[__] world
so much [__] over here that I don't like
over in the states
is really out of this world over here
and um and I've been eating like a
[__] animal over here and I haven't
really been putting on the weight that I
put on when I'm in the States because I
don't know what the [__] they do even
like the uh the chicken
uh
pulley uh
Roti super play Super player right
[__] rotisserie chicken over here I
swear to God our chicken over there is
on steroids I don't know what's going I
don't know what the deal is like we
bought a full chicken and you know I'm
not not gonna lie to you I was a little
buzzed and uh I can carve a chicken or a
turkey like nobody's [__] business
why because I'm some sort of Chef no
because I watched a YouTube video that
broke it down so I'm sitting there
looking at this chicken and like I said
I was a couple of drinks in I couldn't
figure out where the breast meat was
I couldn't tell really the top from the
bottom of the thing because I'm so used
to our Mark McGuire roided up [__]
chickens that you know it's puffing up
like it's going to Gold's [__] gym
over there right
and uh
it's just
it's like they're checking over here
looks like a fitness model right where
ours looks like
who's that guy in the Astros that played
third base that never got busted for
[__] looking like uh the same body
type as Robert Newhouse that's what our
chicken looks like and
um
yeah the green beans are smaller and
they're way more tastier and I was over
here going I [__] love green beans I
didn't know that I think that the ones
we have over where we're at they they
[__]
and I'm not trash in America I'm not
being one of these [__] that goes to
another country like oh my God
everything they have over here is
[__] wonderful I'm not saying that
I'm not saying that at all I'm just
saying that uh I'm actually talking to
the rest of the world that makes fun of
how [__] fat Americans are like they
I don't know
I don't know what happened but there's
something wrong with our goddamn food
um having said that though I would
rather look at a fat American than a fat
European because at least an American at
some point in his life did a [__]
push-up and as some sort of a some sort
of shoulders in some arms and a little
bit of chest on them
these [__] fatties over here
they're just they're like uh
they got like chick bodies
like they never did a pull-up in their
life or anything and then they just get
fat and then they keep wearing the tight
t-shirt
you know
like those gay guys do the gay guys in
West Hollywood I don't give a [__] what
shape they're in they wear a tight shirt
but the gay dudes
in America at least at least have the
decency they're still trying they go to
the gym so they don't look that bad at
least they got they got some [__]
guns on them
you know they got some packs right some
older guy pecks
[Laughter]
I mean I should talk right now that's
what I look like I look like a [__]
Tuesday afternoon stripper right now
with my shirt off you know you could see
how at one point maybe I used to dance
on Saturday night but now I've had like
two or three [__] kids out of wedlock
too so it was a hard two or three right
no [__] alimony even if I know who
the [__] father is he doesn't have
any money you can't get blood from the
stone that dude's sitting in jail
you know it's stupid
he should be out driving a truck
somewhere right why the [__] isn't my
laptop charging ah it's another thing
I'm [__] sick of I'm sick of this
[__]
lack of American electricity over here
ah I'm just a [__] grouchy [__] right
now um
but I haven't said all that you know
we're still having a great time over
here I'm just uh
you know what I realized I haven't
really been vacationing over here as
much as I've been on like a seven day
Bender
that's like
I I gotta get I gotta
stop like at some point we finally just
said like you know when we live at home
you know we don't go out to a bar every
night you just when you're on vacation
you feel like oh I gotta do something
every night and one of those things you
could do is actually relax
and get a good night's sleep you know
and you would think
you know
being uh Cato says or cease how the [__]
you say it
I just did a YouTube thing I said 16
first
soon to be
not catones Katra Katra sets that's what
I'll be on on Wednesday or Thursday
Mercury I don't [__] I just woke up
[__] you
um
anyways uh you think being almost 47
years old
that I would have learned that by now
but I didn't you know and there's
probably a lot of you looking down on me
like I'm some sort of [__] [__]
but now you never really learned that
lesson either what happened to you is
you got married you had a [__] kid
and from what I've heard from parents is
kids don't give a [__] about a hangover
so just because you don't want to deal
with your kid you stop drinking or maybe
you love the thing right
to the point where you don't want to be
the drunk mom or dad but I swear to God
you know parents anytime they get a
chance for the most part they steal away
a couple of minutes
if the grandparents come over and take
the kids they're immediately in The
Liquor Cabinet right
all right well there you go sorry you
know what this really is is me just
feeling like I'm drinking too much so
instead I gotta [__] lash out at
people who never really said anything to
me maybe you're just sitting there with
a kid going hey Bill you know I'm just
kind of enjoying the podcast there's no
reason for you to be a [__] to me
because yeah you're a freckled booze bag
and you know what I'll take that I will
take that you know what you're right and
I apologize
you see that trying to be more mature
um
so anyways uh also you know what the
thing is is yesterday I went to the
French Open and that was like the big
thing that I wanted to do
so I think mentally I kind of checked
out like all right I'm done I'm done I
had the croissants I had the baguettes I
sat in the cafes and I [__] did
whatever the [__] I did I went to the
French Open
you know I took my lady out on her
birthday
I got her a really nice gift
I feel like I'm done like roll credits
and I still got two days here before I
fly back two three days before I fly
back and um but I don't know what this
is
this is the Calm before the storm
you know rather than being depressed
that it's almost over I'm actually kind
of excited because I'm ready to go back
but somewhere around two in the
afternoon
today it's going to hit me like oh [__]
you know I only got another two and a
half days here
and then the drinking's gonna start all
over again
and there is something about the fact
that Jim Morrison died in this town that
you really feel like a [__] if you just
[__] go home
so what I'm saying to you is I'm gonna
be [__] hammered until about
Wednesday
um
Okay so
this is the Monday morning podcast uh
you know what I did the other night
before I went to the the French Open I
got my NHL feed to work and I watched
game two of uh Tampa Bay versus Chicago
and um
what a [__] game what a series I'm so
psyched that I actually was able to see
that because I'm [__] missing the
Cavs Sacramento series as I called it
last week the Cavs uh
Golden State series
um it looks like a classic
I don't think the first game went into
overtime but I know that the the uh
Warriors won by two
and then last night the Cavaliers won by
two in overtime and I just saw the look
on the Cavaliers faces like you know
after they had won it
like there was that combination of
happiness and anger
well you just like all right these guys
are [__] dialed in this is going to
be a hell of a series and I did see
something funny on the NBA website
um talking about Steph Curry it says one
bad night or something worse which is
the classic symptom of all these
different sports Outlets that you know
someone just can't have a bad game all
of a sudden it's got to be uh oh my God
it's the [__] sky falling so
anyways
um
I watched the I watched game two even
though I know knew I had to be up
by uh
I had to be over at Roland garage by
[__] 11 A.M so I had to be up at 10
in the [__] hockey game didn't come
on till like [__] one in the morning
so I was up till four in the morning
watching that [__] going I don't give a
[__] I'm watching this [__] and um
first of all like an [__] I thought
that I had to be over at uh the French
Open at 11 A.M because I just thought it
was the men's final and that was it
and um
by the way I'm sick of people giving me
[__] on Twitter for calling it the
Stanley Cup finals my whole life we
called it the Stanley Cup finals it was
the NBA finals and the Stanley Cup
finals and people go there's not more
than one final well tell that to the
[__] NBA
all right I don't give a [__]
you [__] grammatic [__]
I've watched all of them I've watched
every Stanley Cup Final or final
whatever the [__] you want to call it
since the [__] Islanders fourth
championship all right see going back to
1983 I've watched 33 of them so go [__]
yourself about whether there's an S
there or not I don't care and I also was
calling it the Stanley Cup finals my
whole [__] life and nobody ever gave
me [__] once again maybe that's because
now I just feel stupid and I'm lashing
out at you maybe you were just saying
hey Bill not trying to be a dick but hey
it's the Stanley Cup Final that's how
the NHL the league that you watch
decides to call it
whatever so
I watched that [__] the Stanley Cup
Final until uh 4 AM
yes and um
so we [__] get up out of bed
and uh
we go over to the [__] Subway
and not trying to figure out we we went
into like the where you had to buy the
uh the tickets and it was really
confusing
super confusing there was all you know
which how far into out of Paris do you
want to go there was like three
different level of tickets to buy it was
a complete [__] pain in the ass so we
asked the lady in uh behind the booth
and she was a total [__] she was on the
phone hated her [__] job was just an
[__] this is nothing against French
people or parisians because everybody's
been an absolute sweetheart to us over
here
um and very patient as I try to speak
French you know and um so we just said
[__] it we got out and we got a cab
and we cruised over
and we get over there right and we just
Breeze through there's like no [__]
line
you know I walk into the gift shop
there's nobody in there
I'm looking around I'm like wow this is
some really ugly merchandise and then I
realized it's the last day of the
tournament all the good [__] is gone
which struck me as funny but I still got
a mug a hat and a shirt and a beach
towel
it was a big it was a big bucket list
thing for me I always wanted to go to
this [__] thing so and Nia this is
the funniest thing ever
she was so [__] she was over it
before we even got there she doesn't
give a [__]
she just did not give a [__]
on any level and I was asking her
about something I forget what she said I
just could tell the way she said it
I um I was like oh hey check it out you
know I I didn't think they had my size
but I went over the other side I found
this shirt they actually had my size and
she just goes
oh yeah
and I just started I just bursted out
laughing which made her laugh and I was
like I
I just said to her I said look I know
you don't want to be here
I know like how you're feeling right now
is how I feel when I sit down when you
go to try something on in a [__]
department store
except this is going to take three
[__] hours
so I apologize you know let me go find
you some booze right so I got her some
champagne and [__]
and she's just trashing me
and trashing like the people that are
there and all the [__] thing you know
and just making me laugh my ass off as
she's trying to be a sweetheart go no no
I know this is a big thing for you I
know you're you want to enjoy yourself
here and then and I was just laughing go
look at you you want to just jump out of
your own skin you so don't want to
[__] be here right now so
um
and all I'm doing is looking around
going why and then there's barely
anybody here
and then I thought I figured it out
going oh I know why because there's only
one match today
whereas before I've gone to these tennis
tournaments and there's like you know
this the the the semi-pro things going
on on the satellite courts there's like
you know four or five you know different
matches going on two different venues
some people just have tickets for the
first half of the day some for the whole
day some for the late one so there's
this whole overlapping crowd
and then I realized that that's not what
it was
I realized that it was 11 A.M
and that the men's final did not start
until 3 P.M
and that what was actually happening at
12 noon
was the final for the women's doubles
[__] class
and I realized at that point that Not
only was Nia going to be there for the
three hours of that she was going to be
there for the three hours of the Men
final men's final and uh
and just the look on her [__] face I
feel real bad I completely wore out
yesterday and uh
so anyways and I'm sitting there going
like I [__] hate doubles tennis so
now it's like I I don't all I'm sick is
like we both could have still slept in
because he was sitting there like
zombies because I kind of kept her up
because I was cheering on the game and
everything and uh
so we get over then it's like well
[__] we might as well go in and watch
the women's doubles final and I went in
there and this is the most [__] up
thing dude there was like [__] 70
people in the crowd
for a tennis major final
and uh we went in there and I watched
the [__] match and they at some
points like all right I'm gonna go down
and go get a go get a whatever the [__]
a glass of wine or something and she
goes I need to walk around I'm gonna
fall asleep because you know we've been
sleeping till like one so we've just
as we're still [__] jet lagged or
whatever or whatever because we've been
going out till four in the morning who's
getting who so she had to walk around
just so she wouldn't fall asleep and I
sat there
and I watched the match and I totally
[__] got into it and there was one
American playing Bethany I hope I say it
right Maddox Sans and I was watching her
during the warm-ups and I was like going
she's [__] good man and uh then on
the other team they had this really tall
woman who played up near the net the
whole time and she was a [__] beast
she was the [__] and
right out of the gate it just looked
like the team with the American on it
was gonna lose they just seemed over
matched and all that and they lost the
first set and I'm thinking like you know
selfishly I'm thinking like oh well you
know they lose the first set this will
be over quick you know what I mean they
dropped a second set and then they were
onto the men's final right and uh
they [__] came back
won the second set
and then the other girls women they
[__] Bear Down hang on a second I
gotta blow my [__] nose hold on
and magically I'm back two seconds later
so the other women
they just [__] immediately
the third set they just they just
[__] come out swinging
and it just looks like all right now
they're gonna take over they had they
had a little [__] brain fart in the
second set and
dude it was like a heavyweight fight
then all of a sudden
the other girls started coming back I
really should have their [__] names
the championship names it was uh Lucy
safarova safarova and Bethany Maddox
Sans and they just [__] hung in there
hung in there they [__] broke them
and then they put the [__] hammer
down and they ended up winning it and it
was a [__] awesome game and I swear
to God there was 70 [__] people in
the crowd
I took a picture of it I'll try to
[__] I'm not going to be able to
upload it so I get back here because I
didn't get a cell phone plan because I
always get a cell phone plan when I go
overseas and they go yeah you have
unlimited minutes and texting you'll get
a bill for like 70 bucks and then I come
home and it's always like [__] four
hundred dollars
you know you're always you're there for
like 20 minutes and it says warning
you're out of your [__] minutes for
the day
um
and then what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do you're not gonna take calls
or whatever so I just have not been on
my phone I just shut the [__] thing
off so anyways
so we watched that had a great time
and then we came out and we were walking
around and um
and I don't know I was fighting this
feeling because I always wanted to go to
the French Open and there was something
when I was at the French Open that was
just [__] bugging me
and I couldn't figure out what it was it
was like am I jet lagged am I not
enjoying this because I know my wife
isn't enjoying this and
blah blah blah whatever so
we end up going in to the Men final
right
and uh
it was uh Novak uh Djokovic against uh
this guy oh I never heard of
Stanislas Wawrinka
so I'm sitting there and I see that you
know what's his face isn't in it who's
that [__] guy who wins it every year
uh Rafael Nadal
right that [__] guy I don't know he
won nine of the last 10 of them
it's insane
he won in 2005 six seven eight
one two three four in a row then he won
one two three four five in a row no one
can ever get the six
right Roger Federer won it in 2009
[__] up his his uh
his 10-year run
um
but I mean that's that's one of the one
of them to me that's one of the greatest
accomplishments in in modern day Sports
Blue Fox won nine out of 10
championships
at the pro level you got to go back to
the Boston Celtics when they played in
the 1960s in that YMCA league right
so
anyways and I'm just looking at this
other guy this Stannis loss while rinka
he's like ranked eighth and I lean over
to my wife going I go near a minute ago
this guy's gonna get his [__] ass
kicked all right
they dal's not in it I don't know [__]
about tennis right I just watched the
majors
um and I'm just like this guy's gonna
get his [__] ass kicked this don't
worry this will be over
you know he'll probably win in three
sets maybe four and so she's like okay
all right so I'm sitting there watching
the [__] thing all right and uh
Djokovic wins the first set
and then the second set comes but but
like he only broke wawrinko once
and then the second set this will rinka
dude is just [__] he's coming like a
champ he breaks Djokovic twice and he
ends up winning like he lost the first
set six uh six four and then he won the
second set
six four and when the um
when the set was over when Djokovic had
lost the second set
he [__] uh he slammed his racket down
on on the clay
and he bounced up and he caught it and
then he slammed it two more [__]
times and it broke
and the whole crowd started booing
right
and and that's when it hit me it's like
that's what it is
I don't like this [__] crowd
I don't like the crowd that goes to
tennis matches I don't like how they
whistle when they get upset they hiss
and if you show any sort of [__]
emotion that's like anger
like uh in the first set I think uh that
Wawrinka guy he [__] slammed his
racket down twice on the net they boo
you know because it's supposed to be a
gentleman's game get the [__] out of
here you rich [__] how did you guys get
your money being a gentleman
you [__] Bootleggers give me a break
we got a clothing line you got crying
children sewing the [__] together and
you're [__] sitting here now trying
to tell people how to act like a [__]
gentleman all right this is me judging
these [__] Rich [__] right so and I
realized in that moment I was like
that's why I don't [__] like this
[__] this is why I can never quite
totally get into [__] tennis is
because whenever I go to to a live event
there's that element there
that [__] gray Poupon
pretending to be something that you're
not
you know what I mean like every time
your stock doesn't go down you don't
throw a chalice across the [__]
your manner is just screaming at your
stock broker give me a [__] break and
now you're mad at this guy in his little
short shorts I love when Wawrinka slam
the racket down I saw that he wasn't
intimidated by it I saw that he was
[__] mad at himself
and he wanted to [__] win and I saw
Djokovic after the first Cent when he
won his first set he turned around
looked at his coach and he pumped his
fist and I was thinking this guy's
dialed in and now there's something
about tennis when you [__] blow a set
to have to start all over again
you know at Ground Zero and have to
fight all of those [__] games again
and and block out the fact that dude I
could just be one set away instead I'm
tied and we've been playing for a
[__] hour and a half and we're still
tied and this is annoying like
there's all of that like those moments
where you're starting to give the match
away it's like do you have it in you to
come back and then you're watching the
other person going does this person have
it in them
to finish this other guy off and um
so anyways Wawrinka ends up winning the
third set so now he's up two to one
and I'm like Jesus Christ what the [__]
and then Djokovic just digs in and
[__] comes out and wins the first
three games of the fourth set and I'm
like yeah this guy's got he's got the
championship Gene this is gonna go five
and then this one rinka guy is gonna
have to think like wow man I had this
guy in the ropes and I let him off and
is he gonna have it in him to [__]
come back so these guys are showing
emotion and every time they show anger
these [__] Rich Blue Blood [__] are
booing them
it's like you're watching two [__]
Warriors down here and you're booing the
some of the best part of the game
they're getting mad because they want to
win you [__] this is phenomenal tennis
so
anyways what anyways [__] Stannis
lost just [__]
all of a sudden okay he's serving so
then he wins it's 3-1 and then he breaks
Djokovic 3-2 and then he wins his next
servicing it's [__] 3-3
and I'm sitting there looking at Nia
going like this might be over and forth
this guy can [__] hang on and finish
him off and then also you can finally go
home and sleep and
um
that's what ended up happened uh when
Rick ended up uh
coming back and it was it was a crazy
thing because you know I don't watch a
lot of tennis
and so at first that was for Djokovic
because I knew that he had never won and
he was going to get the career Grand
Slam which is basically winning on all
three surfaces hardcore grass and clay
and then this walrinka guy I didn't
think he'd ever won a major which I
still don't think he did I don't know
[__] about tennis obviously and uh so I
was kind of rooting fan plus there was a
ton of Djokovic fans so immediately it's
like oh man this you know [__] these
rich [__] I want to see the
the Swiss the Swiss guy win just to
watch all these people have to put their
Flags down
well that was another thing too when
people would yell out
you know
all these uh these uh what what is what
is Djokovic she's uh Serbian or
something and when they would yell out
all their Serbian [__] like every once
in a while some English-speaking person
would go shut up
it's oh I'm sorry I'm not supposed to
cheer
that's another thing
about certain these these [__]
hoity-toity sports like like Golf and
everything however he has to shut the
[__] up it has to be perfectly quiet if
anybody like [__] shuffles in this
seat or takes a picture and somebody's
going to putt or [__] go to you know
he hit the tennis ball like the the the
athlete go glares at him
it's like are you [__] kidding me you
hear what people do you see what people
are doing when somebody's taking a foul
shot or [__] trying to kick a field
goal these goddamn golfers and tennis
players they'd start [__] crying
so I don't know I'm not 100 sold on it
but I will say it was it was one of the
great
um events that I've ever been to and I
would definitely go to it again
um
I wouldn't drag my wife to it
uh I've now been to three of the majors
the only one left I have to go to was
Wimbledon so next time I go to England
or something I'll try to set it up
around that and uh I'll go to that and I
won't drag her to it and she'll be like
no I want to go
I like it I like to dress up and it's
like you don't like it
um
so anyways that was uh that was the
experience and uh
another thing too when I got there is
you just can't believe how [__] small
it is
it's like this major it's just Big Time
championship and this it's this little
intimate thing like I swear to God just
go go on StubHub and get tickets sit at
the top of the stadium it'll still be
way better than any seats you'll ever
get at an NBA final
or Stanley Cup Final or anything for the
money and you're not even going to be
that far away and everybody has to be so
[__] quiet you can actually hear him
grunting and groaning like you sit in
Courtside
um
and then the tennis court is just super
[__] small
um
it really is one of the great you know
if you're going to go to a championship
things as far as like a sporting event
that you you that you can go to was
phenomenal and I absolutely uh you know
I've never seen tennis played on Clay
before so that was totally cool and then
I also remembered that [__] hilarious
chapter in John Mcenroe's book where
he'd won Wimbledon he won the U.S open
he won the Australian Open and he needed
the career Grand Slam to win the French
Open in one year he actually had it won
and he ended up [__] up and he blew
it and every time he goes there to
commentate he thinks about it and
um I told you that great thing that he
said but when he was [__] up one year
when he was [__] it up
he screamed at the top of his lungs I
hate this country which to me is one of
the [__] great things ever yelled out
during a game
and of course you know he got booed
which probably made him play better in
the next game which is why I love John
Mcenroe so anyways
so that was my big sporting event thing
that I did on this trip and uh now that
it's [__] over
um
looking back I think I'm just gonna have
I don't know
maybe more fun the next time I go to one
and actually
like I still totally enjoyed it but I
really got [__] annoyed
by them booing him when they showed any
sort of emotion that wasn't genuinely
Behavior
I don't know that just [__] bug maybe
I'm an idiot I don't know anyways
once Jesus Christ I just rambled for 31
[__] minutes let's get through some
uh
let's get through some advertising here
why can't you just write copy like that
why do you got to sit there and say I
have that [__] I don't have that [__]
oh God I'm gonna [__] mood huh all
right
um
all right
oh I saw this this [__] story it's
really annoyed the [__] out of me
surprise surprise
it said uh is this there's this cute
little [__] story and God knows the
internet either likes a we should burn
this person at the stake story or this
little cute ass story like you know I
thought my life is over and then this
kitten showed up and what happened next
will bring you tears of joy I've I
refuse to
this kitten showed up I [__] refused
to read any of those
and I have never told any of you guys
uh you know I just need you just can't
you do me a do me a favor
please stop clicking on those
you know what I mean
I was sitting on a park bench in a
wizard walked up to me and what he had
to say next will change your life and
then you get on there and it's it's like
a quarter of the story and then you
gotta [__] figure out how to click
it's just it's what is it clickbait
that's what they call it all right and
I'll tell you I [__] was able to
figure it out after falling for it about
162 times I realized that all the
stories sounded fake none of this [__]
was really inspiring I never cried I
never laughed I just got [__] annoyed
and I had a bunch of pop-up ads so um
I just I don't know you don't have to do
go ahead continue to click on it who the
[__] am I to tell you what to do
but I always laugh when I read those now
and you wouldn't believe what happens
next uh you won't believe what happens
next is I scroll on to the next [__]
story you douche
um by the way I love Facebook I
absolutely love it I don't give a [__]
if it makes me sound like an old man I
am an old man and I like how they have
all these interesting stories picked out
for me by some other douche on Facebook
rather than having to try to find them
myself so anyway so um
scrolling through the Facebook as us
older people say and um
there was just supposed to be this cute
heartwarming [__] story
it was about how people were delayed for
six hours
in the airport
but through some unbelievable Miracle
the cast of The Lion King Ann and
Aladdin was there at the airport
right and they're acting like this is
some [__] amazing thing it's like no
this is the cast of The Traveling
[__] show this is what these people
do because after it's a hit on Broadway
the people then want to make money and
take it around the country for people
who don't have time the money
or whatever to [__] go to New York no
country can't go to New York and squeeze
into that theater so they have a couple
of traveling shows so lo and behold
you imagine this you're at the [__]
airport your flight is delayed six hours
and then for some reason the fact that
the cast of The Lion King and Aladdin is
there
like this was supposed to be
heartwarming that it made it like a
better thing
this is what happened they started
singing
the [__] songs
to Aladdin or The Lion King just imagine
you're sitting there stuck in a [__]
airport and then all of a sudden some
dude starts doing this
[Music]
oh my God will you shut the fit me would
you guys shut the [__] up
[Music]
right
isn't that what you would say the last
[__] thing I would need
is I'm sitting there hating my [__]
life it's somebody
[Music]
you ever think that most people [__]
hate Broadway shows
all right
I I don't you know there's a ver there's
very few people that actually enjoy
Broadway shows okay it's children
uh it's the gay community
um
oh my God I can't say the next group
because then I'll just get
I'm just pretty
you know and then I don't know I I don't
know it's [__] people who are old
people
you know what I mean who went to who
went to funny girl in Oklahoma and they
actually you know when movies back in
the day when they'd be you'd be watching
a movie and all of a sudden the middle
you have the dialogue they would just
break out into a song and they would
start dancing it's like leftover
vaudevillian horseshit and uh you know
this is like a kids movie
that you turned into a [__] musical
so it sucks on two levels now you've
married two [__] things all right
very very rarely is a kids movie like
like a Toy Story is great
all right but I gotta be honest with you
the whole [__] you know
like pretty much the rest of them like
Bugs Bunny is funny
you know what I mean
pinky in the brain is funny SpongeBob
SquarePants is funny
Sesame Street is funny because they
throw in jokes for adults but a lot of
them you know what I mean
the Care Bears the [__] uh Monchichi
or whatever the other ones are and
that's like Monchichi remember that
Monchichi Monchichi oh so soft and
cuddly Monchichi Monchichi it's a creepy
monkey right they would turn that into a
[__] Musical
and then your girlfriend or your gay
uncle or your your [__] you know the
person who's in the sugar salt [__]
problem right some fatty will take you
to the goddamn thing and you gotta sit
there all right but at least you're
prepared for it when you go to a
Broadway show the last [__] thing you
need I mean is is
oh my God
and the only thing worse than those
[__] people singing that horseshit
would be
the people standing around enjoying it
the looks on their faces
oh my God can you believe it they sing
and like Angels right
they're not it's [__] horrible the
whole [__] thing is horrible and it
was probably written by some white dude
in somewhere in Africa it's probably
really offensive
[__] talking lions and all that [__]
and turning their place into this
Magical Mystery Tour right the same way
when Aladdin came out people from the
Middle East hated that horse [__] as we
ate it up oh my God Robin Williams rest
his soul was [__] hilarious as the
Aladdin right as they're flying on
carpets coming out of tea kettles
they didn't like that [__] either they
didn't like 300 they didn't like any of
that [__] horseshit now you got these
[__] singing at the airport for the
love of God they should have made him go
walk into that little fish tank where
they make smokers go to go [__] sing
in there all right Jesus Christ I'm in a
[__] move you would you would you
know I'm on vacation right now and I am
gay Patty
um
I hate that [__] I I gotta be honest
with you
I'm a bit of a Grinch
um
I have major issues with uh
heartwarming stories
they never make me emotional they make
me [__] angry like that singing there
made me [__] angry
but uh
I'll tell you things that make me
actually get like emotional where I
almost start tearing up
is uh
when I watch
kids fighting on YouTube
and I'll see the kid that should have
lost all of a sudden flip out and beat
the kid that he that should have beat
him that actually will make me emotional
now I don't know what that says about me
but
um
you know
I don't know
whatever maybe that's just not for me
oh my god I've been into so many so many
[__] airports and there's so much
[__] to annoy you the last thing you
need and out of all
the [__] songs to break into
you break into that [__]
that whatever the [__] that is like that
helium balloon what is that [__] people
you suck on like helium
I mean that's like that was what was
just happening there was like 40 Yoko
onos all at the same time
in harmony
singing some like that
that's some [__] that Yoko would have
screamed out
while the Beatles were playing thinking
that she was adding to the music
all right
I might get some complaints over that
one you know
people like you know I always feel like
there's something sad about people who
go to Broadway shows
that's not even true because what's his
face the South Park guys did like the
greatest one ever that I would have gone
to but you know they were sold out for
like nine years and at that point I just
go I don't want to do this
you know what I mean
are you guys like me like I I just like
if there's a line I just I just say well
yeah evidently I'm not going to have
that experience
that's how I just I don't feel like
there's ever a reason to stand in a
[__] line unless you're in a in a you
know
a labor camp
okay and then they hand it up slop
right I was kiddo I'll stand in line to
go see a [__] a good show like a rock
star or something like that but like if
if there's like a [__]
you see how he just subtly covered
myself there if I [__]
I gotta clarify this like
if they go oh my God this place has the
best [__] burgers and I show up and
there's a line around the block I just
go well I guess I'm never gonna have one
my [__] what are we in Russia I'm
standing in the [__] breadline here
I'm not doing that okay why don't you
[__] [__] get a bigger space and
add some more [__] tables
right
is that wrong did this whole thing just
go off the [__] rails I don't even
know all right let's get to some
questions here for the week
um did I get through everything all I
know is I'm really excited to get home
and I'm home for like four days and I go
back out on tour and uh
I am so jonesing to do [__] stand up
um
I I get this [__]
this Bruce Jenner idea that I want to do
that has nothing
and actually I'm not making fun of what
he did what he did actually made me feel
considering his accomplishments made me
feel like less of a man so that's going
to be my angle
on the whole thing
all right here we go
Raging Bull dear Billy the Raging Bull
uh I don't know what that means
[__] or maybe uh I was once a
financial Banker yes one of those Rotten
Scoundrels that wore a monkey suit and
worked like a tool alongside other
corporate douchebags it took me a few
years to actually see how shitty this
industry really was filled with douchey
[__] that would do anything to get
ahead I [__] hated it one day a work
colleague colleague asked me to help him
train for one of those white collar
charity boxing events it basic it's
basically an event where a regular
corporate dude laces up a pair of gloves
oh corporate dudes I've seen that and
they fight each other and they have to
go out in a boxing ring all to raise
money for some Cutthroat charity I know
right
um
oh by the way somebody gave me [__] for
reading that thing about the Red Cross
going you there's a great organization
and you totally classified them
as being pieces of [__] just because of
one bad story and it's like no I didn't
I actually said
that I don't know if part of this is
because what's going on down in Haiti
blah blah blah blah and as I did that I
remembered like wait a minute
didn't they get [__] for uh
what they did during 9 11. so I actually
wrote the guy black back I was like no
no I didn't I didn't trash them but by
the way here's another article
all right with your precious Red Cross
um anyways I he said I've been competing
since I was in college and it was more
of a hobby than anything else so I
agreed to help my co-worker with some of
his training after arriving at my
co-workers boxing gym and watching some
of the other corporate monkeys hit the
heavy bag and Spar I really wanted to
enter myself into this event ah dude
you're a [__] ringer
uh he said these corporate noodles
couldn't punch themselves out of a wet
paper bag and I thought how satisfying
it would be to beat the living [__] out
of one of these aspiring douchey Banker
[__] uh dude come on man you can't do
that
um although it would be kind of funny
yeah body shots funny you can't hit him
in the head
anyways he said I went over the idea
with my Boston Coach he really didn't
approve of the notion of a trained
fighter ripping up some Regular Joe
smoke exactly he goes so unfortunately I
didn't enter the event to this day I
still regret not having the chance to
trash one of those corporate douches in
the ring it would have felt so sweet my
question to you is if you had some sort
of formal training and com a combat
Sport and there was a chance for you to
enter a celebrity boxing event uh would
you love to
who would you love to fight it could be
another comedian celebrity sports figure
anyone who would be across the ring from
you to pummel uh long-term update I have
since left that soul sucking corporate
gig to pursue a year of World Travel
yeah with your blood money and
competition in boxing I'm just [__]
with you too God bless you have a good
time uh seeing you live in Toronto
Pittsburgh
in Brisbane Australia uh keep kicking
ass bill uh
um all right
all right if I was formally trained in
combat like there's no way I would fight
someone else unless they were formally
trained or if they were trying to hurt
me
come on you can't [__] do that but um
sayings how I'm not formally trained
who would I want to fight
and I get to win uh the toughest [__]
guy out there so I look like a stud
um there's really nobody I want to beat
the [__] out of
is there
I'd fight the cast of Aladdin
no I wouldn't do that
that's just a lose-lose either you beat
up a bunch of [__] Broadway singers
or worse you lose to them
um
I'll tell you let me tell you who I
wouldn't fight uh I wouldn't fight Joe
Rogan there's a long list of people that
I wouldn't fight
uh
[Music]
uh Mark Wahlberg I wouldn't fight him
um you know I love to it was all the
people listening right now going dude I
[__] kicked that guy's ass would you
would you I don't think you would
um
who else Ving Rhames I wouldn't fight
Ving Rhames you know what it is it's the
people that that like either are in
shape or they just have a certain
[__] Vibe about them
where you're just like yeah I would [__]
with that guy uh there's a lot of people
I wouldn't fight I don't know 47 next
week most of Hollywood I wouldn't fight
most of Hollywood I would [__] lose
to
um
I I would you know I'd throw a [__]
little girly jab and I would I would I
would hang on and the crowd would boo
like you know when you get ripped off at
a pay-per-view like that's what my fight
would look like
um
no I was kidding who I get hit a couple
times and then I would start spazzing
out and I'd [__] just start doing the
windmill punches before the person just
sat in the pocket and caught me with a
good [__]
I don't know
left hook and just drop me and sit right
on the seat of my pants and make weird
noises all right uh girlfriend a [__]
hey Nia
I should probably still sleeping all
right I like to have her for these
[__] things
all right girlfriend a [__]
in my walk of shame
hey Bill I'm 22 years old and I've been
dating a lady for a few months now
things have been going great we quick we
click really well and she's beautiful
isn't funny all of these start this way
everything's she she's beautiful
it says inelegant girl I think you're
meant to say that's all one word
i-n-e-l-e-g-a-n-t
in elegant
and elegant girl I don't know with uh a
great job
things were going great until recently
she still lives at home and one night
she asked me to come over for a late
night booty call oh Jesus what's wrong
with that dude this girl's a champ so
far of course I show up to her parents
house and get into bed with her oh she
lived at home with her parents okay
that's kind of weird as I laid down
as I laid down
I sat on a vibrating sex toy
she was embarrassed and played it off
like oh I just found this recently when
I was cleaning through my stuff
I acted like I didn't care but in my
head I was screaming what the [__]
um dude why are you acting like you
didn't [__] rub one out like the day
before
yeah but I use my hand I went all
natural what are you looking at her like
she's a [__] she's using Peds here
um anyways we go at it and I spend the
night at her place I love how you were
like what the [__] but you still banged
your classic guy moved dude this chick's
a [__] psycho Wanna [__] okay
in the morning it turns out she wasn't
home alone her dad was home and when I
do the walk of shame
and I do the Walk of Shame out of the
house oh my God the dad saw you
OMG on top of this
wait on top of it this was the first
time meeting her dad we didn't say a
word to each other and he just gave me
this death glare that screamed this
[__] just bang my daughter in my
house
oh my God
her dad flipped a [__] on her and wants
her to move out she asked me if it was
cool if she lives with the two guys from
work I tell her I don't care but again
I'm thinking
uh what in the actual [__] is going on
here basically how do you think I should
play this out should I cut my losses and
get out I try to stick it out I feel
like those are some serious red flags
but I really like this girl and until
this point things were perfect maybe the
lovely Mia could help yeah she needs to
help I would say this
um
uh yeah she could have been a little she
could have handled that situation A
little better
uh with her dad uh Christ you know what
I don't think knee is up so
what do I do do I disappoint you guys or
do I do I let my wife sleep on the
vacation
let's go wake up my wife hang on
bonjour madame
Nia
can you help me out with a question here
are you still sleeping
all right I'll give it to you real quick
all right
all right here's the deal this kid's 22
he's with this girl she's [__]
perfect everything's wonder wonder
everything's wonderful
all right uh uh so she calls him up one
night for a booty call he goes over
there she's still living at home
and he's like all right our parents are
at home so he goes up there he goes like
I get into the bed and immediately sit
on one of your vibrating sex toys
and he's she tries to play it off like
oh that's just something I found
when I was going through my stuff and he
said he was he played it up but was like
what the [__] he thought it was weird
he's 22. so
she [__] they Bang
he wakes up the next morning
and it turns out her [__] dad is home
so he's got to do the Walk of Shame
right past her dad
and the guy is just glaring at him like
if you just [__] my daughter in my own
house get the [__] out of here so he
gets the [__] out of there right
and then uh like the next day at work or
something she goes yeah my dad's pissed
at me he wants me to move out do you
mind if I move in with two guys from
work
and he's like part of him you know likes
the girl the other part is like you know
there are too many red flags here
what's red flag about it
that
I don't know they is this his girlfriend
she gotta turn towards the mic
oh
yeah oh you're here yeah
[__]
okay yeah sorry I had to [__]
recorder
[Laughter]
um what's red flag about it
well first of all it's like this is his
girlfriend
she used to booty call earlier right so
if you're talking about booty it's just
the beginning of a relationship here and
he's like do I pursue this
I want to ask her why she felt it was
necessary to ask him permission about
where she wants to live
right but obviously that's not the
situation here
she's moving in with two guys that they
work with
and
I mean and that's a little [__] well
what if okay let's flip the tables you
and I just started hooking up hey is it
okay if I move him with these two chicks
that we both work with
oh they all work together yep what am I
[__] Jack Tripper you're not gonna
have a problem with that
I think I think kids these days they uh
they live together males and females and
it's not like a big deal so
um
if I were like her mom I think it'd be a
different story but um
no I don't understand well because I you
know because I would just be like a mom
about it you know but as as a guy who's
just uh hanging out with her
yeah but you just she just [__]
banged you when her dad was home and
then made you and then just [__]
doesn't even have the decency to be like
hey my dad's home you might want to go
out the [__] window and you walk by
the dead like he's like that he's done
like what's he gonna do have a
relationship come over for [__]
Thanksgiving like his first [__]
meeting is yeah yeah I [__] just
railed your daughter right up above you
like that if he was if he was mature at
all he would have been like oh good
morning you know my name is so and so
and I just [__] your daughter well
obviously you don't say that but what
the [__] what are we reading all night
no you say hi you know I'm friends with
such and such and how are you you know
you do the respect then no the
respecting was to not say a [__] word
to sit there and come down and be like
hello how are you and try to play it off
like you didn't [__] is insulting that
man's intelligence well anyway getting
back to this no no no no no let's let's
stay with that point there okay there's
no way out of that situation other than
what he did the most respectful thing
that he could have done was not say
anything because he's at least as a man
addressing the fact that he understands
that what the [__] he did even though it
wasn't on purpose was ridiculously
gonna [__] with this guy's head I
disagree I think what you should have
done is is
been respectful and said like he saw him
like he walked by his dad yeah he would
yeah he walked by and the guy and the
guy's staring [__] daggers at Nia
they did [__] 22 years old
okay I'm just I'm just saying I I think
it would have been better if he had uh
introduced himself because that's can
you please do that to me I'll play the
dead well that's the respectful thing to
do I'll play the dad just you don't just
walk through somebody like a a grown
person's house and not say anything
that's something my parents
would have felt like you know you don't
just walk in my house and you know what
I mean like I've almost seen what you're
saying here but it has to then it can't
be more than two words
like I would have just looked at him I
would have been I'm sorry
we're talking about the red flag
situation right the red flag is that
he's he's this girl is sexual and so
that to him is a red flag and you know
what baby doll you need to [__] get
over it
you know something there I understand
where you're going with this word it's
just like if a guy he masturbates just
like you do all right
all right she wasn't smart about putting
away her vibrators maybe she was
thinking that you might be kind of like
oh what is this but you know you're 22
you probably don't know how to use it or
don't quite understand what it's about
he's 22. he doesn't need it his dick is
standing at attention when he [__]
wakes up in the morning not for him
I don't mean for him I meant for like
they could he could use it on her like
that's what I meant
what the [__] you think I meant you
saying that she would no no I'm saying
that he doesn't need it to pleasure her
Jesus Christ let me there's confirm what
I was saying
okay but there's other there's other
ways get that 22. I know Bill I'm saying
that this other [__] you can have
like a nice strong dick that goes all
night but you can also use a vibrator as
well like you know this don't make me
explain this to you you know what I'm
talking about
I do okay all right thank you for giving
me credit
yeah yeah
um listen to you I don't have a listen I
agree with you next story it's a you
know it's something whatever all right
he's he's not ready for it it's fine the
point is that he
it's fine maybe one day he will be um
but the fact is he just was like oh my
God this is a sexual girl and she
doesn't really give a [__] who knows it
right whether it's me who came over for
a booty call because I'm like whoa
what's this vibrator doing here or you
know her dad so she would you took it
now I'm no I'm just trying to think how
you mistook it like when I said his dick
stands up when he wakes up like he needs
to use her vibrator make his dick go up
like that doesn't even make any sense to
me I
I didn't think it made sense either but
it was obviously a miscommunication yeah
I was looking at it like it was like the
stuntic like that's what like when you
know those old guys in the steakhouses
who have like the [__] chicks half
their age like they show up with like a
bag of like [__] Viagra in them
like a vibrator because you know to keep
her interested as they're waiting for
the blue pill to kick in
that's how I was looking at it Jesus
Christ let's [__] clarify this [__]
so anyways my my thing is Sonia is
like just the situation that she put
herself in and put him in where he then
has to walk by the dad I mean the whole
[__] thing is just taking on water
right now no it's very messy
it's it's it's a very messy situation
for sure so there might be a lack of
maturity on her side though which these
ready to like I mean if they're yeah
they're both 22 I think that goes
without saying but yes okay you just
won't give this girl any sort of
criticism here and yet listen I said I
just said they're both 22 they're both
22. yeah both we've already you've
already [__] all over this guy I'm just
saying like how am I sitting all over
the guy
I'm just saying I'm not it's too early
to get involved in this [__] argument
let's let's just let's just plow ahead
let's just plow ahead here what is the
point that you you're trying to get me
to address here is that is maybe she's
not ready to be in a [__] she just got
kicked out of her house for [__]
another guy yeah in the house yeah okay
that's you know that's not a very stable
situation to get involved in first of
all you're 22 years old so you're still
picking in the first round it's not like
the guy is 42 when he's single and he's
going to take what's out there there's a
whole bunch of [__] you know this
this is this is like you hit the NBA
draft lottery you get like the first
[__] pick in the draft here you're
gonna go with the [__] a woman
who just got kicked out of her house for
[__] you
while her dad was still home and you
walked by her dad
all the vibrated [__] and anything yeah
who gives a [__] about all of that the
[__] that part there I'm saying does he
really need
to Hitch his wagon to that so you're
he's asking if he should like
pursue a relationship because everything
else everything else other than her
[__] two doors down from the dad and
then having him walk by the Dead
I mean there are some things near that
right in the beginning this fight of how
nice you are and everything there are
some things that make you kind of go
like hey you know what
you know relationships are hard
even when you're with the right person
you know Jesus
um
yeah no I mean it I I would say
young man that is that you're just trash
it you you condescended to the ground I
was trying to be funny excuse me
um Jesus [__] crash I know you're the
professional comedian in relationships
oh relax why am I here then you know no
you were trashing the guy so bad I
thought that that was another part of
the trashing
we're just not uh we're not uh we're not
uh and and in sync there this morning
there kiddo um
I would say that uh yeah you you it's it
doesn't sound like uh she's the girl for
you how about that there we go yeah that
wasn't so fun hey I did that hopefully
I'm gonna leave out why I don't think so
but yeah I know why because he's he
because because he's not mature enough
to handle a [__] blah blah blah blah
obviously they're both immature all
right you know I like about me walking
away is your your voice is fading away
in the background I gotta go downstairs
where the [__] uh yeah where the
where the [__] uh
questions are
all right
in your little attic Loft here don't sit
up too quickly you'll hit you hit on the
beam again
no Jesus of Ramadan
we got a little tree Ford apartment here
um all right here we go that was a
[__]
waste of goddamn I thought I thought she
was finally gonna agree with me just one
of these times I wanted to [__] agree
with me she just won't do it just will
not do it all right um
ah [__] this thing's gonna take forever
to load this [__] slow ass internet
here let's uh
I gotta read a couple more advertising
then I'll blow through these last couple
of questions all right Trunk Club
everybody Trunk Club
guys you might hate shopping but you
still want to look good right what if
you could snap your fingers and have a
trunk full of clothes that fit perfectly
and make you look amazing you're gonna
love what you get delivered uh you're
gonna love what gets delivered to you
from Trunk Club at Trump trunkclub.com
you answer a few simple questions about
your look style and size and then they
assign a real person who helps to style
you they email you a list of clothes
they recommend sending you uh they
recommend sending you you approve it at
no cost to you they ship a trunk full of
fresh new clothes to your door try them
on keep what you want send back what you
don't in their prepaid box that's it a
better wardrobe than you could ever pick
out yourself in minutes or maybe you
could pick out of just as good a
wardrobe but if someone else is going to
[__] do it why do you need to do it
right did I mention the service is free
your stylist the shopping the Box even
the shipping all 100 free when you go to
trunkclub.com only pay for the clothes
you keep no ongoing subscriptions no
hidden charges no malls just great
clothes hand pick for your style
all right you're going to thank me on
this and right now it's completely free
go get started at trunkclub.com today
that's trunkclub.com all right and
lastly but not leastly
LegalZoom are you the next World Famous
entrepreneur or maybe you don't care
about Fame I do you just want to help
people uh whatever your motivation if
you're an Innovative it's easy to launch
your dream this month with legalism
incorporate a form and LLC to start your
business register your trademark to
protect your products and services apply
for a patent to secure your invention
these are all fragments and they keep
having like apply for a patent to secure
your invention
is that a fragment register your
trademark to protect your products and
services
so you need a subject you should I don't
[__] know maybe I'm wrong Bill why
are you diagramming sentences just read
the goddamn property over the past
decade legalzoma has helped more than a
million people just like you turn their
ideas into reality so what's special
about this month well for a limited time
you can get special savings on any
trademark copyright a provisional patent
application go to legalzoom.com today to
get started they even can help you if
you have a great idea but you're not
sure where to begin since they are not a
law firm you can get advice from
legalzoom's network of independent
attorneys in Most states that means you
can get the guidance you need to get
your great idea off of the ground don't
forget to enter Burr b-u-r-r and the
referral box at this month's uh at
checkout this month for your special
discount legalzoom.com promo code Burr
legal help is here
all right
um
all right where am I right now all right
sister is a [__]
Jesus
all right hey there ginger head man
though I get it a little play on words
there oh Jesus I'm a 20 year old guy who
desperately needs advice from from their
favorite comedian
from his favorite comedian
so I'll get to the point my sister is a
[__]
Jesus Christ
this guy's not pulling any punches here
to give you a small sample of her I'll
elaborate a bit
all right so you can get a small sample
you're going to elaborate
this guy's just [__] he's he's
yinging and yagging he's digging and
zagging uh she's a narcissist
she's a narcissist to her very core and
straight up stupid
she sounds like she's hot
she is abusive to my dad oh she's
definitely good looking even though he
has cut his room in half to accommodate
her moving into a small apartment she
hurls insults at him and when she
doesn't get her way and talk [__] under
her breath
um
wait she hurls insults at him when she
doesn't get away and talk [__] under her
breath so we can't hear it but I can and
it's [__] infuriating my dad is a
really is really is a good man who has
worked as a teacher for nearly 30 years
and I respect the hell out of him it
kills me to see her treat him like
yesterday's dog [__] also she's a
massive [__]
Jesus buddy this is your sister
since I almost know
I I almost know that she sucks dick for
weed
all right dude this is getting sad here
truly she is one of the most ugly and
insensitive people that could ever exist
in addition to that she loves to talk
about how good she looks she's lost a
lot of weight and while I was supportive
At first she rapidly became began to
make fun of me it made me feel bad about
my body to prop herself up dude this is
like a reality show
this is sad on so many different levels
uh fun fact she starved herself became a
bulimic took weight loss pills and never
worked out
so what the [__] gives that [__] the
right to say anything to anyone about
how they look all right dude you got a
lot of anger towards your sister you
established this now I need your help
with your unique attitude of take no
[__] dude I take plenty of [__] how do
you handle it's easy to not take any
[__] was was a [__] individual on a
podcast not talking to anybody how do
you handle someone like that I'm sure
you've met hundreds like her
what can you say what can you do to
reign in this psycho [__] she abuses my
dad she treats my little brother and I
like total [__] and she doesn't do
anything to keep the place clean so that
usually falls on my dad and I all she
does is use people and when they aren't
useful anymore she discards them like
trash she's truly someone I've grown to
despise and resent I try and keep her
out of my mind as much as possible to
keep my own sanity uh I would have
disowned her but since she lives with me
it's it makes it difficult I feel bad
for my dad because he has to watch my
sister and I argue I always have my
dad's back and yell at her when she says
some of her usual crap that doesn't
really do it anymore but that doesn't
really do it anymore
I'm not someone who has problems with a
lot of people most of the people I've
met
who know her have told me similar horror
stories if you can't think of anything
to suggest I gladly accept it if you
just bash her on the podcast it won't
solve anything but it will give me
something to smile about when I see that
dumb [__] come hopping into the living
room acting like a [__] doesn't stink
thanks for hearing me out Bill all the
best
to you Nia and Cleo all right
um
well you are living in some cramped
quarters so that's definitely going to
make you guys not like each other
um
it doesn't seem like your dad calls her
out on her behavior
so
um I would say
I would start working on my own life
which is I would make enough money to
move out and I would if she's truly as
horrible as you're saying
I would uh try to just see her on
Thanksgiving and Christmas
and
[Music]
um
you know that stuff about her being
bulimic and starving yourself and taking
weight loss pills
um
is definitely
probably should be addressed at some
point understatement oh look who's back
Look Who's Back old cutie pie
I'm kind of glad you didn't see all this
this guy just said a bunch of horrible
stuff about his sister I thought that
she's a [__]
well and she also seems like a complete
sociopath that she just kind of uses
people and when she can't she's got a
lot of [__] going on it sounds like but
this is also just sounds like a mess but
it's also if she has an eating disorder
that's a whole
maybe she's just dizzy
no sorry my [__] no someone eating
disorder that's um
that's hardcore
because like if you if it's like really
I knew a girl always bulimic but she was
a really nice person she wasn't walking
around treating people like [__] so I
think if this girl had everybody not
everyone's gonna like go about it the
same that's what I'm saying so maybe if
she has like a full belly she'd still be
a [__] that is very true or she yeah or
she's like I'm a [__] just a mess
this is kind of like when people have
addicts or whatever as siblings and they
feel like everyone is sort of like
tiptoeing around them and they're like
this person is a [__] jerk and an
[__] why are we you know and I'm
doing all the right things like I don't
understand why they are
being tiptoed around and that's it's not
fair yeah I think all three of them her
her little brother and her dad
should uh say like listen if you don't
stop acting the way you're acting you
got to move out
that's basically it
and then when she you know Stomps around
like some [__] you know Clydesdale I
wonder if they ever had any like good
times together other than when they were
like six or something like had they ever
like gone out to eat and and I have no
idea what's going on with you like why
are you so angry all the time or it's
like her Behavior's so bad that you
don't even want to be in the same room
with her but I heard what you said that
he should move out that's basically
the best solution I think is just I
think she's watching too many of those
[__] shows where you know she thinks
she's got to have some [__] certain
kind of shoes and that type of [__] her
dad's a teacher they're living in this
small ass apartment and uh I think she
wants the Finer Things in life and she's
going to get it however she needs to get
it so right now she's like all right I'm
gonna get all skinny I'm gonna [__]
bang my way to some weed and a nice car
and I think you got a full-on sociopath
on your hands that's what I think and uh
I think you guys need to gang up against
her tell her to [__] get her [__]
together that she has to move out and if
your dad is
can't get past the fact that that's the
apple of her eye and he doesn't want to
do anything then you got to choose
yourself and I would move the [__] out
that's it
all right awful laugh oh my God Neil we
why are you saying that she's in
sociopath I'm just curious
um because she tweets her dad's like
[__] she [__] uh uses P this is his
description she uses people and when she
can't get anything from them she
completely discards them which means she
has no use for them but all right
they're like they're like a light bulb
that that burned out
all right I understand what this card
means
sorry I just had to ah Jesus all right
you know what I deserve that all right
awful laugh
hey Mr Bill birth canal
they always they try to come up with
clever ways to uh with my name I say hey
Bill ginger head man instead of
gingerbread man that's good that's
decent right that's all right all right
I need the brilliant wisdom that only a
middle-aged balding redhead could give
see that this is how they do it they
compliment and they slap me around a
little bit uh I'm dating a lady
who couldn't win a Hooters model contest
wow she could win a Hooters model
contest fly that girl in a Paris and put
her on the runway at Chanel
sorry why do you guys hate
why do you guys hate it when we say
you're pretty no no it's not that it's
just like that it's supposed to be like
this [__] ultimate compliment that
she can win a modeling contest at
Hooters I'm I'm any other woman who's
and this is nothing against Hooters
actually because I don't alligator
garments [__] on Hooters go ahead but
I'm saying like it's just funny to me
what men or young guys consider a
compliment she could win a [__]
Hooters
I'm sorry if there's any girls that work
at Hooters I [__] love Hooters and
their girls are super you don't like
Hooters and you don't think it's suited
you're insulted by it I'm not it's I'm I
think it's funny the way he describes
her as saying she could win a Hooters
there's something really funny about
that all right there was something funny
about that but I'll tell you this stuff
you think about you got to go on the
road with me down here okay you got to
go on the road you gotta understand you
know when you live in the middle of
[__] nowhere
you know and you give big deals you go
down to the [__] Cracker Barrel and
you and you get that you get you get
down to one little golf Pig and that
means you're a genius that that's out
there Nia out there you think I'm being
classist by laughing at that description
because he can't just say she I this
girl is really beautiful because he goes
off I'm actually a funny intelligent
level-headed and as a smoker that's
those are wonderful things but like the
Hooters model contest first of all I
didn't know that they had model contests
you mean that she could get a job at
Hooters
because hey again can I get a word in
there
I was actually I was being a dick oh I'm
joking around I love Cracker Barrel and
I love when I [__] get down to the
one little golf spike it makes me feel
like I am intelligent they got that
little gaming I haven't been a Cracker
Barrel in a million you shouldn't
because they said that racist [__] a
long time ago yeah exactly and I betray
our relationship every time I go there
and get their eggs
um
all right she's funny intelligent
level-headed and has a smoking hot body
I'm an epic chest ah wait maybe that's
where the Hooters part comes in yeah
she's got a great [__] wreck and the
Hooters model contest all right I'm
sorry what should you said Applebee's
[__]
an incredibly subpar
looking restaurant chain with the most
basic requirements you realize what a
snob you sound like to be sitting here
in Paris [__] on Hooters [__] you
absolutely [__] you you know what no
question for you today Mama Zell but
absolutely I love it I love their
popcorn shrimp
yeah you see them good don't ever forget
that man don't ever [__] forget that
I don't ever forget I don't give a [__]
where you're at or what you're doing at
the end of the day you like Hooters
lemon popcorn shrimp not lemon popcorn
shrimp the lemon pepper wings and the
Buffalo popcorn shrimp that [__] is
amazing and they have really big drinks
it could be a little stronger though at
least in the Hollywood one but uh no I
don't I really don't have a problem I
just saw the final 10 years of your life
what you've just an absolute Lush
sitting next to a pool why is this
[__] my TV bigger eating [__]
lemon chicken wings oh I would never
have a martini at [__] Hooters I mean
a margarita maybe
like that's the kind of place you get a
fireball shot
you know what Nia
you really sound gross right now
all right this is my fault anyway let's
go on it's my fault both are looks and
personality shut up I'm reading this why
would I complain you ask well because
you're a guy and so you have to complain
about something
because everything wow that sounds
familiar I feel like putting a bullet in
my head it sounds like a coyote and a
trash compactor
we're at dinner at Hooters I assume she
laughs as loud and as awful as she can I
can see all the shock tables in my
peripheral vision and hear the babies
nearby begin to violently weep okay now
you're being hyperbolic uh when whenever
she laughs I do my best to stare at her
rack and appreciate her until the storm
is over this is actually kind of funny
this girl is practically wife material
with every laugh I lose the will to live
I'm a 26 year old man with options
right but really oh you know what you're
such an [__] you just [__] all over
the guy this is good you bounce it out
nothing the guy said that whole [__]
hyperbole thing if some woman wrote that
like a coyote and trash compactor and
like the babies crying around there you
would have laughed oh my God this girl's
hilarious but if a guy does it they're a
[__] [__] let me finish this out I
got you buddy here we go this girl is
practically wife but 26 year old male
with options he does have options and
what's Facebook now the world is his
option oh grandpa
I'm sorry what is it Instagram
is it a meme is that how you meet
somebody now
[__] meme but realistically I don't
know if I have the potential to Top This
girl uh dude you're selling yourself
short what do I do do I suck it up and
look past it or do I put on uh what do I
put on the breakup suit and dump her
moments before leaping out of the car
your advice and possibly the lovely
knees would be wonderful it calls you
the lovely Mia and you're [__] on
them I'm sure I speak for many when I
say yeah okay
sincerely possible suicide victim all
right dude you don't love this girl
enough to look past her laugh because I
really think if you really loved her the
fact that she had that crazy laugh you
it would it would actually in some weird
way you'd find it adorable uh I think
she's just hot that's true I think she's
hot I think you have a little bit of low
self-esteem where you're looking at your
age like what what do you what do you
got [__] eggs in you you don't all
right you're a guy you're young forever
you know your biological clock isn't
ticking you know yes I just say this
[__] just to get you going all right
yeah 26 year old yeah you got all the
options in the world she's [__]
smoking hot right bang her one more time
and then [__] dump her right I'm
sorry I'm [__] with you just just get
out of it just get out of the
relationship and uh and that's the thing
though but don't tell her why
don't say because you're [__] laugh
because she can't do anything about her
laugh Nia I know I feel bad
I feel bad for them both
because it's like I'm trying to I was
just trying to put myself in the
situation like I you know being crazy
about you and if you just had like the
worst lap yeah yeah like
we know somebody that has a laugh like
that that's like kind of like has like a
honking in their laugh and it's and it's
funny but I'm sure the first time the
person he's with heard it she was like
whoa okay but the thing is a person who
laughs like that other you laugh at them
for their laugh they laugh even more
everybody laughs at them and it becomes
like a like that girl if you love them
if you love them you're right if you
don't you're like oh my God is it really
that bad like is it I I wish I'm not
gonna say the name I'm not gonna say the
name but I used to have somebody at one
of my agents that's what I was just
talking about yeah one of my agents but
I love them to death and I actually
loved his laugh especially because you
could hear it when he was in the crowd
and I knew that he thought the joke was
fun money and he'd seen a bunch of
Comedy so to really get him to laugh was
an amazing thing I feel like I can hear
it right now yeah so I would I remember
being on stage at Caroline's and I'm
killing for a half an hour and I and I
knew he was in the crowd but I'm not
thinking that I'm just thinking of doing
my [__] and about a half hour and I
tried this new bit and I riffed this
thing and it [__] killed and the
middle of it I hear in the back of the
club just here
yep the honk yeah but I'm not even doing
the thing yeah
and uh yeah and he and he hated his
laugh too he hated his laugh he's just
like I know that's how I laugh and blah
blah blah blah but uh [__] sweetheart
of a guy yeah but he was a great person
we're talking about it like he's dead
now he is currently
uh I gotta wrap this podcast up because
this internet here stinks and this is
going to take me forever to uh
to upload this did I really go an hour
and a half [__] uh really quickly Mia
sorry sorry for the uh
getting you there too early to the
tennis match you hung in there like a
[__] Champ oh did you talk about that
yeah I basically said that I had a great
[__] time but but that crowd is not
my crowd no
tennis crowd
I mean let's let's continue the Hooters
crowd is in your crowd either Nia I love
the Hooters crowd well maybe not the
crowd but the restaurant all right I
like the Hooters restaurant the tennis
crowd is it's it's a weird one because
you've got all this shh and then you've
got the Rogue person that's like come on
Casey like when we were Australia you've
got people getting mad they get mad at
somebody yelling people who scream out
because it's like they have to
concentrate kind of like if you were to
do that on a golf field I feel like it's
a similar thing right literally what I
just said oh okay it's a golf course
yeah so it's weird but there's this
aggression to it as well yeah it's a
golf course not a golf field
did I say Garfield the golf Stadium when
you're at the golf Arena all right I
have to wrap this up because this
thing's gonna take forever to load all
right okay all right that's it once
again thank you for everybody for
listening thanks for writing in all of
that [__] I got the uh I got my tour
coming up
um when I get back I can't wait to do
stand-up
um
I miss it man I [__] miss it
um let me read off the dates here uh I
will be in Portland Oregon
you [__] love that top
never even heard that Portland Oregon
you ever been to Portland no did you
come to that one I would love to no I've
spent enough time with you no I've spent
enough time with you I'm Sicky Portland
Oregon this is true listen let me I'll
tell you some of the best [__] food
Portland and Seattle unbelievable I hear
it's beautiful that's [__] awesome
full of cool ass people it's [__]
unbelievable Sacramento California I'm
going next June 19th June 19th I don't
know [__] about Sacramento other than I
used to say in this horrific Comedy Club
condo across from the punch line out
there and the only thing I could do is
walk to this dirty McDonald's where
there was this crackhead so I I I'm
holding out I thought Sacramento was a
bunch of really rich Republican white
people
um not the part I was staying in WoW
um Reno
Reno bizarre guitar and gun shop
definitely going to swing by there Santa
Rosa never been there
I'm playing that on June 21st uh June
22nd I'm in San Jose I've been there a
bunch of times I love that [__] Town
Fresno never been to Fresno only thing
I've seen there is about gang activity
and they have uh they have a good uh
they have a good football team well they
did I don't know if all they've been
doing the last couple years uh then I'm
in Bakersfield California then Highland
California
I don't know why it just sounds like yep
Buddy Baker Brewster Baker remember that
show Kenny Rogers that's why Brewster
Baker Kenny Rogers field PD do you
remember that show
that show nope okay then I'm in Las
Vegas on the 26th at the Mirage and then
I'm in Tucson Arizona how [__] cool
is that tour all down the west coast and
uh it's Arlene Schnitzer the Arlene
Schnitzer Concert Hall who is that
somebody who died but accomplished is it
a woman that invented something perhaps
did you tell them about accomplished
enough in life
tour that we went on and how you were
you turned to me and you're like a woman
inventor shut up BB oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah we'll we'll tell that next time
okay that sounds good no no okay
is that what it is
yeah she wanted my wife is such a drunk
she wanted to take she wanted to take a
tour of how they make champagne yeah so
we get in we [__] drive out to the
countryside and uh went to this really
cool ass town I forgot what it was
called and we took a tour of this thing
and uh I hate champagne gives me a
brutal hangover I don't like sweet [__]
right
um so
they used to have these Minds where they
dug for chalk
and he went down like these these oh
shut up they went down these 80 [__]
how do I get through this it's such a
cool [__] story I'll tell it on
Thursday
anyways long story short a guy actually
came up with the [__] and then he died
at 27 and then uh she was the love of
his life
means the Widow and that was the last
name she kept the last name of her
husband that died and she took over the
champagne but she [__] perfected it
and took it to the next level and an
invented a way to get that sentiment out
of it to make it clear as [__]
um and she kind of did some [__]
scumbag [__] though that all great
companies have to do if they're gonna go
internationally when Napoleon lost to
the Russians
okay french guy they lost to the
Russians and the Russians wanted to
celebrate she [__] sent them over
champagne
to the to the people that [__] just
beat not exactly patriotic but yeah it's
[__] horrific but I'll tell you right
now political moves yeah but you know
what every guy especially International
son yeah she actually behaved like a
bank dust they got money on both horses
whoever wins they still win like Don
King but at a [__]
corporate level all right I'm done go
[__] yourself so I'll talk to you on
Thursday I'll check in on you